this video is sponsored by liquid
IV more on them after the reaction
people
bonjour I Really Work to remember that we
are here today it is John and Greg in the
hot seats to watch Ridley Scott's Napoleon a
topic a figure of History we both know a ton
about are you excited G I am so excited I've
watched every movie Napoleon's ever made I've
read all of his books I've bought his art I
know everything about him I'm going to p on
this PO s is what I meant to say yeah
yeah absolutely me too I'm excited to
watch French Joker so hey leave a like on this
video also don't forget to subscribe and hit the
notification Bell to get notified every time one
of these movies comes your way as well thanks to
the gang over at prepper for helping us chop
down these highlights and if you want to get
the complete Napoleon experience all six hours
of it alongside Greg and myself come on over
to patreon.com theal rejects grab your own copy
sync up with us enjoy the movie as well as all
the other shows and movies we have watch alongs
and highlights for over there it's a blast it's a
good time and I think that's all the housekeeping
let's go let's let's go to France let's do this
thing did you see a tra for this I didn't
see a tra for it nope I've heard a couple
reviews like vague like just like oh
it was good or not but yeah otherwise
no 1789 man I Don't Know Jack about Napoleon
nope people are tuned to misery to Revolution
and brought back by Revolution to misery
ni we said French have disillusioned by
food shortes and widespread economic
depression haha anti-royalist would
soon send King Louie the 16th and 11,000
of his supporters to a violent end and set
their sights in the queen of FR missed it
missed something about Queen let him eat
cake packs a thud is that the
guillotine oh even just the sound effect
imagine going out that way that's Kirby in
this WOW
sheeps was a simpler time boy she's
just being treated like the ex-wife
of every celebrity yeah this is what she deserves
yeah off with her head off off off
oh is that song about Marie Anto yep
yep you can learn most of the plot of this
movie just by listening to the y [Applause] y
I do like the music being very much in contrast
with the horrendous Terror that's about to take
place for this poor individual or do I not like
her I don't I don't know yeah does she just she
have this coming was she detached from oo
feels so real will and needs of her people
I know they never focus on that part where
they're sliding the brace down you know the
human head lives for several seconds after it is
decapitated that's what I'm looking forward to in
life sweet
sauce oh cool let them eat
stump oh there's your
boy feels Quirk quirky yeah now she was guilty
of three charges against you and high treason for
acting in the interests of the enemy sheep yeah
she deserved to have her head cut off the British
Navy have taken the port of tulong half the French
Fleet is trapped there if we lose those ships the
Republic will fall well we can't let that happen
there are only 2,000 English troops in tul we are
short of artillery and led by a general who was a
court pain who it's an idiot it is not necessary
to recapture tulon itself the town is not a town
the town is a port homeboy is not even attempting
an accent NOP this is going to be one of those
every Accent movies I think capture the fort
that dominates the harbor and you have the city
we must make an example our other cities will
fall and I for one will never let the royalists
or the English take my region yeah no surrender
it's good response man when it
comes to sets and stuff red Le
Scott knows how to hire the right people every
time Luc and my dear brother
I'm in too loan already and it
sucks going to need a lot more cannons this
looks like a really fun set to be on if we
do not succeed those in power will only see us
as corsan Ruffians unfit for higher office and
our mother's Ambitions will be quashed and
corkin Ruffians are no bueno yeah bad ombr
I got to simplify some of this for my brain
surprise is my advantage but I will win by
fire I cannot wait for your arrival your
brother Nao win by fire that is a way to
end a letter so he's scouting this seen right
now in disguising himself as just a regular
civilian yeah the classical music provides
a bit of like a Whimsical tone that I wasn't
expecting and I mean the film does
have like a classical feeling sort
of sense of scope and and just I don't
know the way they're lensing everything
and the austerity of a lot of the Landscapes and
stuff
drink and always bring people together no
matter where you are in the world and what
time Napoleon seems so terrified
right now so nervous it's a big
Revolt I mean he's making his
rise he's not Napoleon just
yet breathe Napolean you got this
man
flying by the seat of his
pants [Applause] whoa ah cool it's
one thing we can all relate to is
rebelling against the British
I miss this kind of action in
cinema his expression are great keep it [Music]
together man all these stun
workers and Extras get the up
there what a fun set the explosions
happening on on the actual
stage what the [__] oh I that was not
expected yeah what kind of movie are we
in that was extremely violent David A's
Napoleon David A's your reference sure
I'll take a David a Napoleon why
we just watched Fury the there's
Battlefield horse Gore you know very
realistic depictions you're not used to
seeing get up there Napoleon team Napoleon yeah
that's what you're supposed to
take away from all this oh my
god oh sweet I want to start a counter
of how many heads get lopped off across
[Music] [Applause]
this damn it's so weird to see him without his hat
on
Jesus wow cool this some cool
violence I know ready to get
him yes sir oh look at him he's
coming into his own he's focused
yeah come on
Napoleon you know he did job
this is a beautiful looking film
woo thieving Pirates great
shot this is a very whoa very striking
time period aesthetically always damn
they really built all these ships I guess
maybe maybe they Miniatures some of them
but beautiful wow you can like feel the
Flames what a formation Napoleon buap I award
you the rank of Brigadier General my man do we
like Napoleon we love Napoleon okay who's your
favorite French dictator comment below he's a
dictator eventually not yet though okay
now he's just the commander or whatever
I promised you brilliant successes and I've
kept my word brilliant success although it
is a little confusing that we just defeated the
British and half of these French Dudes at British
accents I'm happy for you buddy that was
a really well done sequence because it is
fraught and dark as it was it was still
able to keep up with everything that was
going on and it does like dip in and out of
just like the chaos of war in this point in
time where it is so personal and
just like people up against each
[Music] other for mother Jesus Christ for
mother what kind of mother did you have
the current leadership of France has passed
from enthusiasm to Reckless ambition and the
public perception of the guillotine
his Lawless passion my ROP spear oh
he is unfit to Ru robes Pierre has a rep
throughout history for sure is Napoleon
asleep yep my man there is no man in this
room who has objected to my methods if you
say I am guilty you are all guilty oh that's
what I say in my relationship only I can fix
thisr arrest him well they just come
to that how fragile the rule of law
is that dude just doing like a people's elbow back
there yes was my tiny gun
whoa yeah
coward oh my God
a guillotine my friend I thought he was going to
be like it's real all right it's blood son of a
[__] I know it's just a time and place but when
you do [__] like that it
just keeps reminding me of
pirates end of the reign of terror are we
about to celebrate bastile day or something
here every French viewer of this video is
going to be like typing in the comments
Non-Stop the movie should do a good enough job
communicating what's happening without us having
to read a history book that's that's true if
it's a good enough adaptation of the novel you
know wow like an ancient
witch Rider
[Music] gadriel uh I saw the opening
scene that is not an accurate
depiction it's starting to come back to me she
was very out of touch with the needs of her
people from what I recall vaguely from history
the irony of the let the famous let them me
[Music]
cake in true classic theater
fashion no women on the stage
Savage I mean it is highlighting how
thin the barriers between savagery
and civility are yeah people
complain about comedy today
yeah just walking in the room looking like
Joe Pera hello my name is Napoleon and I'm
going to lead us to Victory you know
we're in France baby no sense of human
decency we're in the enlightened part
of the world all right we're in Bohemia
Prime damn she looks way different with that
why you staring at me Liz Salander hair am I
I was not oh you w she said yes before he
said no I was not I was star at your face
face at your face what is this costume you have
all this is my uniform I let the French victory
at too long he just wanted to drop that line
tonight yeah you were just waiting for anyone
who would listen do not tell me your name I will
guess it give me 200 chances yes like that while
this is high society everyone's still like a
little sweaty and like Caked Up like it looks
like the real version of high society you're
a young man who wishes to see you his name
is yenan name oh Easter egg oh he's from the
first one what do you want my father's saber
it was taken from him before he was arrested and
executed we need new Kaiba crystals I cannot allow
citizens to have weapons in their possession
the sword is a Keepsake for me to remember my
dear late father perhaps but it as a weapon
nevertheless how do people like prepare food
my mother said that you were the only Dem man
of authority to retrieve the sword who's the
mother that
light all of these are from officers who were
sentenced to die did no one think to attach names
to any of them no there are no names damn find
a needle in a needle stack take the most Rusty
one kid going to be like this isn't it
I know the sword anywhere he does have
a very relaxed presence on in this
time period like he he fits in in
a way that normally people be a little
more pushed in the way they behave thank
you there she is yeah you knew it
there's the majer my compliments
to the chef of this fine family he's hallucinating
[Music] her is he touching himself right now is
this his fantasy yeah clunk clunk
clunk clunk would you like to St
[Music] closer did they intentionally
make him shorter maybe I know that's
a debated part of the actual
history as to like whether he
was actually short or if people
just did that to taint His Image
later oh it's a date will you be my
boyfriend yes no maybe what did he
just too he's just being sensitive you
know she probably perfumed it Napoleon
wouldn't be Napoleon if it wasn't for
her yeah this is real love right here
chemistry unmatched when you look
at me do you see an aristocrat or an
aristocat no my husband had more than one
lover and when his head was cut off all
his Mistresses watched she weren't alone
when I was in prison I I was told the only
way to survive was to get pregnant
yes wow do I need to warn you of my
indiscretions no Madam I don't
give a [__] just where I have
been concern you pastes the past well
like how many were we talking here like
ballpark of course if you look down
you'll see a surprise once you see it
you will always want it this works yes Mommy this
works people of France don't be fooled
there are more of us it's fascinating can
occupy this convention this movie is framed
like paintings but it doesn't behave like a
[Applause] painting no doubt you've seen the chaos
in the streets yes can you hear it yeah it's like
happening right at these new windows are really
soundproof there is a belief amongst the committee
that there is an attack on the council coming by
this mob I have less than 4,000 troops and very
little in the way of weapons there are 40 cannons
in Sablon I could have them here in 3 hours this
mob is 20,000 strong yes you don't need to take
down all 20,000 though what would you intend to do
if this assignment of defense was transferred
to you uh tread carefully I accept on the
condition that I command this as I see fit without
interruption in devastating Victory via my water
slide royalist Insurrection fifth
October 1795 just get it done Napoleon
yeah let's go what a harrowing
ass shot The Emptiness in those
eyes wipe them out Napoleon
3 hours later
[Applause] wow wow wow who your foot I mean you
had to get the job done it's true somebody had to
make the tough decisions Marie Joseph Rose Tash
except as her husband Napoleon bonapart Dynamite
do you consider yes I do I'm already like very
suspicious of how accurate this love story is
yes it seems like the very Hollywood thing to do
the whole here's who he was as he rose the ranks
and became the dictator we all know and love and
then we have the love story like but here's where
he was a human yeah and the love story while I
am intrigued does feel like the the most elevated
or Fantastical part thus far but I'd love to be
wrong of the Republic Madam Bon mad Bon hey here
here kill that man this I'm going
Napoleon side man if we're going to
watch us through his lens I am going to experience
it rooting for him yeah this movie is
an endorsement of all of his views and
actions dude dude a with your breasticles hanging
out like that don't be getting jealous dog you
said you were going to get jealous if I see my
wife talk to another man I think about that for
a long time and contemplate doing something hi
so for those watching the YouTube cut Napoleon's
trying very hard to satisfy his woman yeah
and she looks um not moved At All by this
experience after that love making scene I really
see myself in Napoleon man yeah man pull that bone
apart just like I know what it's like what yeah I
follow Alexander the Great and Caesar as I've have
been sent to liberate Egypt I have 40,000 men and
the sights are wondrous and the weather stifling
hot sure plan for attacking England through their
Eastern Empire that's what I'm talking about but
my achievement seem slight as they keep us apart
I mean Napoleon might not be physically small in
this movie but he does have an inferiority complex
sure massively so wow the freaking pyramids
dude dude oh my God man's got to do what a man's
got to do that's right that's right no matter how
wonderful the world dear wife this love I have
for you is a kind of death a little death yes
Petty more there's no survival for me except in
you hell again what are you doing good morning
Luc if you love me you me twice a day who are you
doing tell me there are no snakes in your bed in
your legs inside what is mine write me and tell
me that you realize that I love you beyond the
limits of imagination chea of which I have much
you cheat on a great man like this yeah a great
man wow all the locations and I I really
feel like you can feel the weather in
each scene you cut to I know and then it
makes it all the more fascinating that
Ridley Scott shoots like four movies
a year and then they still feel like
completely entrenched in where they
are there's a lot of like film making
technical Marvel on display with consistent
pensive music that plays yes with a hint of
irony whoa tip toing give
me PA get me an Apple box
damn respect oh I got a little bit of a
haircut give him a Wet Willie I
want to do that thing's going to
disintegrate What secrets did it whisper to
you from Beyond the Grave are there limits
to what I can tell you only you create
the limits no shouldn't be should I tell
you something at the risk of giving you
personal pain he's going to find out his
wife is cheating your wife has taking a
lover named eite Charles what a name too
why would you cheat on this guy troops
we're moving out we got to go get my
wife this guy's like I told Napoleon he
just left my fault he didn't believe me
he said go for it do more more lovers
you expect me to believe this yes and
my wife would do this to me yes no
dessert for you you may leave punish
him I wouldn't like my dessert please ah
yeah what a great
frame you think that was intentional
yes like is this the master lucil is
my lover she writes to me Josephine's lady
in waiting is your lover strategic Choice
prepare two frigs and two smaller vessels
in the greatest secrecy I'm returning home
no you shouldn't be seen as desertion why
did you tell him now you should have waited
yeah dude General c will be informed of his
succession to command after I left man she's
ruining the war yeah come on dude keep your
head in the game you changed bro you Chang
she's just like every ex celebrity's wife
or current wife when celebrity is having
downfall oh my God made the headlines wow it
has oh my God and a cartoon to boot this is
not going to bode well for his inferiority
complex damn dude they leaked the texts if I
was him I'd start with the children yeah and
from yeah punishment's all around where's my
wife she has left to greet you in Leo
whoa dude where is my wife Jesus she
left earlier today General Leon yes sir the
entire world knows of my arrival but not my
wife such a little boy such a little boy so
petulant yeah she's terrified for her life
oh she grown her hair out too to demonstrate
the passage of time John yeah or she put on a
wig Oh no you're lucky he's just kicking you
out man he could easily behead you yeah and he
did pack your [__] what kind of creature are
you how could you care so little for me and my
feelings you are a selfish little pig wow not
try to touch his hand sorry a that's not enough
I wouldn't forgive this man I want you to say
that I am the most important thing in the world
yeah wow I relate with this guy so uh never mind
you're the most important thing in my life and
without me you are nothing I'm nothing and you
will do anything I'll do anything wow this is
like watching us on screen I'll do anything
like we've had this exact conversation yeah
and then we turned the camera on and started
shooting Theo you're a beast oh man he's just
going to put you down forever you're a freaking
Beast bro I feel sorry for you oh my God this
is a fireside chat you want to be great you
are nothing without me say it wow the power
oh I mean he's got like clear mom problems
he took the cannon out of the horse and gave
it to to her yeah yeah do you love me yet you
are just a brute that is nothing without me I
just a brute that is nothing without you
yes let's go how can you be on her side
symolon you sad sad little boy did you have a fast
of course I did well yeah but that's different did
you love them no no I did not oh okay never mind
they could be on our he literally left the war to
come home and talk about this were they pretty
yes some of them some of them who more than I
do they cried less that made them more attractive
bars yep just you don't have to forgive me just
promise me you are be sometimes it's easier just
to stay in the toxic relationship man these two
are made for each other what is it that made you
desert your troops in Egypt my wife was Bowman
boning a man boning while we were apart what
country are we in because she doesn't resemble
the France that I left who should be responsible
for her governance while I'm away because it is
not you citizen go wait way to flip this my
man this it's not you certainly you are you
truthfully you're very good at scowling it's
not you baras or you ton or you SE I'm going
to remember all their names yeah yeah that one
guy opens a diner later on I have returned to
France to find her bankrupt printing money that
is spent within hours chapter 11 ostr Russian
overrun of Italy the anglo-russian occupation of
Holland and what appears to be the IM an invasion
of France herself well we cannot let that happen
no someone's got to fix this and yet you accuse
me of desertion oh my God great that's right
man you take the take control of the situation
there is there's a lot to learn from this man the
people will accept my rule if I have your support
like you that I believe that the directory
is corrupt Trin that swamp but together we
can save this country from a restoration of the
monarchy and we can preserve the ideals of the
Revolution and I think that a seizure of power
is possible oh good so you expect me to be your
sword more than that I expect that a kudeta well
timed well executed could transfer power into the
hands of three consols yep myself du and G and
you boom I'm inviting you to The Winning Side
oh yeah do that that'll show your wife that'll
show your wife and your mom letter of resignation
I'm not signing anything you can piss before
I sign anything wow look at those murals my
God I'm going to make this very simple for
you oh good I have documents announcing
your resignation from the council
I feel like Paul and him were cool
yeah citizen Mulan We have a letter
of resignation for you to sign oh I
am enjoying a succulent breakfast this isang
i f finished my breakfast before you catch
me oh it's
okay you fly away you're free now go get out
of here the coup at Christmas this is a very
interesting tone this emergency session is
to draw a list of number n minations for a
a new directory to deal with the threat all
right let's get it going we are being asked
to pass a resolution forming a provisional
government to three councils yes and we have
three of mine General bonapart and citizen
CZ and rer du where are the five members of
the directory please stand up your brother
Napoleon bonapart with his show of military
might is acting as an outlaw pull it together
Napoleon pull it together Napoleon no enough there
is wow man viated the
wow damn wow you can really feel the
camera here yeah oh my God the first
time I became aware of a camera yeah I
know right whoa fing Phoenix really do
that sure looked like he did I believe
he would throw himself into that there
go oh my God walking Phoenix with his funny
Escapist runs we are being terrorized by deputies
armed with daggers and these Mad Men have outl
themselves godamn right way to Twisted on the
liberty of this country who is this guy I've
seen him in stuff they're trying to kill me
they're trying to kill him Jesus yeah there's
so like actual comedy in this movie oh this is
absolutely like a comedy dressed like an auster
history you know piece that like this is lowkey
hilarious there's a there's a black comedy here
it's really really odd strange it's cor quirky
as [__] well it's got all like the posture and
import of like you know the weight you associate
with history but it's also highlighting yeah just
how Petty and small so many of these people are
shall we vote shall we vote my
manad style points for
days oh [Music] yeah there some soundproof
[Music] [Applause]
doors and just like how flippant the people
in charge are with like all the stuff that
dictates life to the people below like good
to meet you is that his Mommy ah could this
be Joseph oh they haven't met yet Josephine
good to see you Josephine oh it's Charles
immediately disinterested finally get to meet
your daughter-in-law and no interest mom but
but did you did you see Mom what about what
I need from you is a better understanding of
the Russian Zar Alexander would you consider
the Zar an ally to England or France his trade
with England is more beneficial to him than his
trade with France and you have a sense of British
influence in the Russian courts uh-oh I do not
but I imagine it is quite robust robust explain
this word robust what kind of man is he describ
him what does he look like well he's young is
he hot he's vain he's popular and he wishes to
remain so statue right behind him greatest fear
is to be killed in his bed like his father this
makes him dangerously fickle to whoever last has
his attention he run the m city they knowbody
he check the lock every time you walk by the
door tand your majesty received a letter
of peace from the first counil today peace
over to us are clearly only for you all
handling a French public opinion wowe but
my warning to you is that he's as hungry
for it as any man in the history of the
world so my suggestion would be to take
little offering of peace from him it's
no little offering man yeah or suffer the
consequences for a man bent on peace at any
cost where's John Cena they know how to Veil
their threats in such clever ways I know I
wonder how many people like left all these
different conversations like not getting the
undertone I think he was threatening me are
you aware of my letter of peace to your king
I am not shall I repeat it you may not take
this as a warning to your king I will keep
you guessing you will watch your borders
and your back and your manners are bound
sooner or later to be French bam and I will
take the lack of a swift reply as an act of
disrespect you think you're so great because
you have [Music] both I want to say that to
somebody she's so good at playing Manchild yeah
seriously so good at that plays it quite a bit
developmentally stunted that would be the
type cast I would play for walking Phoenix
sure Manchild the European families think nothing
more of you than a Corsican Thug uhoh I suggest
that you're abandon your role as first counil
of France why would you think this wouldn't
make him mad for the title Victorious counil by
another name King wow bring the monarchy back
baby king who decided these hats they all wear
he could become king yeah you could just make
it so I guess just change the structure around
a little bit you know the blueprint it's already
exists my hair has been set the
way you like it what beautiful
come what is
is he like clopping like a like a horse
[__] it's yours thank you thank
you it's the most unflattering scenes
just the dispassionate scenes they have
here yeah it's like meat hitting other meat
that's it like there's no real chemistry here
why aren't you pregnant uh-oh is that a
question that an accusation yes it was a
question now it's an accusation now it's an
accusation God that little dip he took with her
chair what I've seen Dr CA and he has no answer
well maybe you got to get on top yes the gravity
you do a headstand afterwards along with hopeful
thinking and a bit of red wine I suggested I take
the waters at EXA Chapelle and what happened you
as wife of the first console I haven't found the
time I spend many hours cleaning up after you yep
imagine doing this as Queen queening up after me
I don't need to explain to you the importance
of this do I what you want an a I want one
now my God show me how the piggies eat at least
he's so playful with her oh my God it
is the one way in which she seems to
play Napoleon not have children
maybe not he didn't have a nappo
baby Vanessa Kirby man she's got that Elegance
yeah oh he was allowed to attend this damn dude
president poing didn't do anything about
him may God affirm you on his throne and
Christ give you to rule with him in his ATT
Kingdom this guy knows a lot about Christ
the King I can do whatever I want and with
his Caesar Halo I found the crown of France
in the gutter I picked it up with the tip of my
sword and cleaned it and placed it at top my own
head King wears a King hat and sits on a king
chair not a thick ass Crown damn yeah how do
you how how do you be stacking these crowns
with these Tiaras and the most AUST Napoleon
is crown and inro long live the emperor live
the emperor [Applause] Hallelujah we are about
like a little over an hour in and I am wondering
what the overall cohesive narrative is ultimately
going to amount to though yeah I kind of just feel
like I've been watching like some interesting
highlights over so far an interesting character
study highlight re showcasing how petulance and
idiocy could just get you all the way to the top
yeah I'm like is this going to be a rise and fall
kind of movie or something or is this going to
take us to the Pinnacle just to drive the point
home but I'm half worried we're just watching
like a sequence of events happening yeah without
any real sort of strong narrative yeah structural
end point yeah you suggest divorce after years
of debate you can see that it has me divided I
not ambitious I've never declared war with anyone
you are the greatest leader in the history of the
world and the world's only chance at peace this
guy's this guy's so smart he knows he has to like
tout his ego yeah he needs to gas him up security
of the Empire and peace in the world depends upon
an hand even if he doesn't believe it he's just
trying to control the situation he could just have
an affair with another woman can't he probably
child count I mean I'm sure he could fudge all
the you know rules and or what information gets
out and make it work yeah change the law that
only can be heirs I'm going to war to defend our
people and my wife cannot provide me an air wow
what a thing to bring up in front of everyone if
you do not bear me a child tonight there will be a
divorce damn Jesus this is a private conversation
hasn't been enough love making in this home to
Bear a child ow there have been years of it years
smash every all every day and with more than just
me wow this is really uncomfortable you're
empty you're fat I enjoy my meals dad bud get
it are you warmed
up man this guy's just like Elvis Presley from
the Priscilla movie yeah it's my favorite Elvis
I love your talent and your taste and while I'm
away I will miss your grace and your dignity how
many poems you read to inspire that line look
I'm always here for you Francis but I must
admit I'm overwhelmed with the excitement of the
battlefield I should not deceive you Alexander
this battle against him will be brutal and
terrifying oh but it will be great for the
camera it'll be righteous that'll be what we
showed up for aets I don't know anything about
him p in but this movie portrays him in kind of
a f in a really fascinating light he a Manchild
that when it came down to it he knew how to
get the job done seemed like he always lived
up to the word yeah he knew his fascism boy on
this day we celebrate the first anniversary of
our coronation my previous Ally has now joined
with my enemy damn our Alexander joined forces
with the prince of Austria yes I have heard
that he's been studying The Art of War sunu
sunu yeah he tries to copy me a little boy
who will make a terrible mistake I'm going
to do the opposite of everything I am certain
I will bring the Laurels of another glorious
Victory to my Army today Napoleon back watch
so many different locations we've been going
to this isn't going to be great
for y'all seems like whenever they
have to go to war with England they
have to always take down the Allies
first everything's different
when you're going to fight Russia
interesting I wonder what that code is that
means we're ready to attack Your Majesty we
are discovered never mind discovered tell
the men to rest gives me an excuse so keep
my eyes closed yeah doing my meditations i
n f infantry i m t INF FJ IM man the horrors
of that where you have to just just rise
to the occasion of War just relaxing one
minute well and and to be far enough back
in time that it's like hey the the opposing
enemies coming how far away are they all
right keep resting though we we need you
at your best like it must not feel real
until it actually is happening yeah so you
can see the whites of their eyes or just the
ranks of their formation this this is pretty
formidable opening fight a gladiator was in
the snow let them think they have the higher
ground they got all this fog to work in their
advantage it's poor horses man it's made a lot
of dead horses this was a terrible time to be a
horse wowe attack these hay [Music] bales oh
jeez there's that Zoom send in the Infantry
take their position on the higher ground have
the double uh way to cook let's cook let's cook
yes yeah Circle them in this are beautiful
visual effects the scope and scale is truly
captured wow like it feels real yeah from the
West here's their place with them Flags out
now go after them yeah run
away wow staging of these sequences
no I like these little nuggets of real
life yeah I figured there you go use
that ice so at ease wow what a shot
wowe yeah oh y' done for the action is the best
thing about the movie yeah it is gripping oh I
love that blood smeared in the ice water blood
in the water a poor horse a that's sad oh boy oh
boy s like some Mel Gibson War violence here
yeah can you imagine Mel Gibson is Napoleon
wow what a sequence holy [__] that is
maximizing your artillery it's a Slaughter
I mean every time and place to fight is is
horrific but like you you watch this era and
you're just like oh what misery this must have
been like oh man you're just like drinking in
the blood at that point yeah at everybody on the
surface just getting mangled off the ice withraw
but everyone's got such cool helmets cut off their
Retreat make an example out of them wow dude wow I
can't tell what's CGI and what's not other than
like some of the cannonballs but this all looks
real like the explosions Jesus oh my God cut off
their Retreat don't even let them surrender it's
a little literal Slaughter Francis so nice to
finally meet you so nice to finally meet you H
where am I ask is Alexander are we waiting for his
arrival before we get started he will be joining
us he's beside himself with rage he says [__]
I realize I must compliment you for making me
commit an enormous error an error huh what error
have you made to be speaking with you here and
accepting this invitation for peace I have not
followed up my victory no I could have taken the
whole Russian and Austrian Army prisoners yes
toast it's so weird because there anything but
intimidated yeah but this is yeah it's like
it's the luck of living in a time and place
where it's so easy to craft and manipulate like
it's they capture it in a way like this is just
what he does yeah you know like I don't really
feel like we're really more into the mindset of
Napoleon or why Napoleon is the way he is or how
he became to be this genius in the battlefield
like all these things that like this movie kind
of keeps you at a distance on the biopic side
of it and it just portrays it like this is just
something he does his job yeah totally it just
illustrates like you know in this time and place
the the minations exist to where a guy like this
can just Waltz his way to the top he just seems
like so effortless at it at at this like RIS at
the when it comes to the battlefield stuff like
we don't really see the struggle or anything we
will conduct a very practical experiment oh
my thank you mother waiting for you undressed
ready to for see his 18-year-old Elanor denel
de plena oh you can just impregnant her there
you go she's brunette with brown eyes and the
object of this hardly unpleasant task is to see
if you can father a child are you going to have
an equal test for Josephine is it Josephine or is
it her we will have an answer to this ni agging
question of who is keeping who from an heir to
the throne of France who is keeping you from your
Napo baby it's not the same that's a supportive
mom yeah it's the mom who's going to have your
back mhm frankly I don't feel like Mrs Humphrey
would do the same you know you'd be surprised
I would be surprised when you are one of my
subjects you will regret making that [Music]
remark a buddy [Music] oh mood lighting so he
can imagine her you think so I think he really
just is like head over heels for Josephine and
so you made her pregnant damn just like that
do even care they do like cut through time
in a way it's like this is so weird to me yeah
sometimes they give you like a subtitle to tell
you what you're just like we're yeah like if you
didn't without that line of dialogue I would just
assume that he came right back out to the party
if I succeed in making the birth of a boy that I
shall call my own son I want you as a witness to
pretend the confinement of the empress youranus
you are asking me to lie about the status of the
mother of your Heir yes yeah dude no one's going
to find out I cannot contain that which I know to
be the truth and painful though it is the truth
is that the the empress is no longer capable of
bearing you a child ouch how did that happen wow
just married the 18-year-old yeah Chuck the old
one out into the snow my good Josephine you know
how I've loved you it is you to you alone that
I owe the few moments of happiness I have known
in this world my destiny is more powerful than my
will wow my affections must yield to the interests
of my people the Imperial decree the dissolution
of the marriage between the Emperor Napoleon and
the empress Joseph wow that is a horrible cuz she
could not bear a child my people desire that this
Throne where Providence has placed me would be
given to my children however I have lost hope
of having children from my marriage oh my god
oh this is so mean I've then been led to listen
only to the good of the state and to want the
dissolution years of my life this is my burden
you heard have embellished my life for 15 years
the memories of which will remain forever etched
in my heart sure our marriage has become an
obstacle for the prosperity of France she has
been deprived of one day being governed by the
descendants of a man brought To Us by Providence
to menend the evils of a terrible Revolution oh
Jesus and restore Faith the throne and the social
order oh my God you're ruining our God where we
started versus where we are [Music] now this is
this is for your country that's what this is right
whoa this is so humiliating yeah our marriage has
become an obstacle for the prosperity of France
agreeing to the disolution of our marriage as I
must does not change my feelings slap will damn
I love the stifling laughter from her the emperor
will have in me always his his truest friend
oh I could still keep her around in some way
as my affection slave this guy has no idea how
to process emotions you have just pronounced the
word which separates us forever your mistaken
ambition has ever been and will continue to be
the guide of all your actions he could have had
true love you can never doubt the sincerity of my
wishes for your happiness really yours thank
you Josephine dude you get to go back back
to you know your pick of the litter you're good
unless I'm missing a horrible history fact yeah
she's going to get assassinated right here
Cannonball just rips through blows her head
off I thought she had children yeah maybe I don't
know maybe he cast them out into the
street is he visiting her right away
yep jeez I miss you it's been four years has
it what what movie my child is about to ascend
the throne youve shown such great curse so
far so brave you are in being without me do
not permit yourself to fall into Melancholy
I feel like we'll get like a scene with like
a great like oh here we go good ending and then
then we do like this jump like oh we could have
like and then there will be another SLE with
the drama yeah will you write me tomorrow mhm
and the next day the day after that like as an
edit it's trimmed it's paced well for an edit
uh at the same time you could tell that like
shit's been totally cut out yes oh sure yeah
yeah like they make it it's paced well like
the pace is consistent um but it is there is
stuff like like he said you French you fight
only for money while we English we fight for
Honor oh here we go I replied everyone fights
for what they lack this is not your story this
never happened to you did it that was a sick
burn we have the same saying with my people in
the turke oh no would be my absolute pleasure
and honor if I could call you my brother is he
does he have like a Russian accent there is a way
for you to call me brother last night my dinner
I was Charmed by your sister oh wow she's to be
married to the Duke of oldenberg I'm afraid well
intervine Napoleon yeah is there a formal offer
for Anna she is 10 well you see and Anna she's
15 years old that is a detail he is Elvis Presley
yes yes all great men are our friendship is built
on our mutual distrust of when we hold to the
Continental blockade we choke them from the
trade and we fight for our most sacred rights
that is what is important between us I've just
had a thought write this down imagine an army
marching about way of Constantinople into Asia
would have only to reach the Euphrates to make
England tremble and bring her down on her knees
before the continent dope did you have a pleasant
journey it was wonderful thank you do you need a
bigger hat she seems a amored by him you're quite
PE I'm not accustomed to that CU Napoleon short
how do I look to you do I resemble my portrait
yes even more handsome and strong oh oh my would
you like to see the bedroom yes would I oh my
God she seems way more into him come my child
bride the child your majesty
your son which one put him
[Music]
there what's going on
outside oh no that robe though come meet my
baby why are you doing this dude oh because
does she still owes him a baby for love man that
is so [Music] mean a can you raise this for me I
want a different one make this a king yeah I
want a different one you could have this one
you will understand what I have sacrificed for
you when you watch a Ridley Scott movie yes my
dear Josephine I'm sad today still rites to her
SAR Alexander has turned against me and forced me
to invade Russia he's decided to open his ports
to England wow I must wipe away my Melancholy
and begin the march to Moscow just the types we
and so I command the combined forces of France
Austria Italy Germany and Poland sometimes they
just feel like they don't let enough things sit
yeah we got a director's cut to maintain that
was I was like oh man we're getting somewhere
like every time it has me it's like just and is
this to a part of the war 182 the war stuff are
so visually interesting but in terms of emotional
heft to add to the story it's just kind of just
turn it doesn't really thrust anything it's just
like oh here we are it's not the exact right
word but it is like the more repetitive element
because once you're back out in battle you're just
watching a battle it's definitely like engaging
when it's happening but it doesn't really add to
the doesn't feel like it's developing the story
uh yeah the emotional experience in the chair
oh wow
ruthless oh he's got a a little
bit of horse riding form on
him oh my
[Music] God
that excellent profile shot this is
epic whoa 28,000 they lose that battle my dear
Josephine I'm writing to you because I've just
won a great battle today they won okay did
they dude this dude's always coming out on
top Moscow is now only 200 miles away and I
think of you all the WoW all yours I think
he's just telling himself so yeah they they're
not winning [__] right now oh he lost okay
but he needs this to yeah he needs to convince
himself by telling her the grave [Music] of at
least he still survived run in battle like
that and walking out of life yeah where are
you oh boy where are you 300,000 Souls live in the
city and they've all just left where is everybody
boy let's get some John Woo action in here they
all just Retreat from him I think this is a
trap they is this her way of surrendering
it's not very sporting is it for his honor
in Russia is not mine yeah I suppose
so Birds [__] all over this throne
uhoh wow God damn rather just burn it all to
the ground that a hell of a shot though wowe
who did this they did they'd rather not no they
did not be sensible no they would do it they are
spting you sir your majesty they did God he'd
rather burn his own city than negotiate with
me I didn't think he had the courage called
this courage yep we'll get to St Petersburg
and have him burned that too you're just going
to walk into town yep we have let too much time
step away we would be marching into the Russian
winter good if we go back to Poland we can wait
out the winter month yeah they're counting on this
remember that I alone know your health your fears
I thank you as tenderly as is I Will Always Love
You Josephine my friend Josephine it's like he's
winning but not really it is strange to write
that word to you you have always been so much
more you've always been my ba we are winning it's
one way put Fortune has abandoned me I know that
it is what Fate has for me your words rattle
in my head I am nothing without you does he
have any relationship with his current wife not
that we got to see it's in that 4our cut of the
600,000 men you sent to Russia only 40,000 have
returned therefore you have been Exile oh damn
jeez that's 560,000 deaths the Allied Coalition
of Austria Prussia Russia and England and with
the agreement of the French Council Grant you
sovereignty of the island of Elba Elba dude
it's your Birthright a revenue of 2 million
Franks from the French f fund pensions for
the bonapart family and the empress Mar Louise
what a severance package that is yeah it also
provides for Empress Josephine to retain all of
her properties an a lotted annual income of 1
million Franks what a severance package Jesus
but it was never really about the money was it
no no he did it for passion all I've desired was
its glory and would never bring our Misfortune
oh you already did they want me to abdicate fine
I'll abdicate wow wow and I I wonder that must be
real it's the other thing too is he's
talked so much across this movie about
his people and his love for the people
and the people's love for him and we
almost never see just the regular people of
friends oh yeah know yourness and oh my God
I would load if she gets pregnant with
his kid you do not have to lock yourself
away just because he's not here I know
what it is like to be underestimated and
your spirit it isn't there it is yours and
you can use it empowering ass [__] right
there oh [Music]
no he's still in his uniform nah he's pathetic
dear Josephine you are mine you will always be
I cannot stand it any longer longer it has been
300 days on this rock and I'm ready to come home
and reclaim what's mine Jesus you and France
dear Josephine you still ain't called a root
I hope you had a chance it's been 300 days in
the last two minutes John yep yes it has he Ain
lying this this could have been a mini series
freaking like his History Channel highlights
oh now bring me my water slide open your mouth
please why is she poisoned or pregnant she must
got uh what was the ashes ashes We All Fall
Down oh she's got the plague my suggestion
is to stay in bed she's got some disease the flu
thingy she get tuberculosis tuberculosis that's
and is it illegal for Napoleon to step
foot here sure I would imagine unless
we missed something but he was exiled
he seems like he's just yeah de gaffing
and coming back a ship landed on the
beach in on this morning and they are
on the March Napoleon bonapart is
marching towards Paris who's with
him a delightful Fanfare this is all for
Napoleon General Marshall in defense of
the Royal government of King Louis VI 18th
request that you surrender your weapons and
cease your March so that you may be arrested and
return to your Island will you please inform the
general that I should like to come and speak
with him I have no fight with my own Fifth
Army still done a lot for them yeah you know
I mean that's why they're giving him the
severance he wishes to speak nah ready yeah yeah
we done talking bro and that's how Napoleon died
soldiers of the fifth regiment do you recognize
me I am your daddy do you recognize me soldiers
yes Emperor oh dude he got one loyalist I miss
you I'm Melancholy for my home bored as hell
and for our victories together yeah he did give
us victories I want to come home will you join
me the hell just happened says like four
sentences oh my God uh this is going be real
bad news but damn that influence he held wow
sure some variation of this happened but yeah
damn all I guess King Louis the 18th I really
earned their respect he led them to a lot of
Victories and he was always out there in the
field yeah he wasn't just chilling at home
bonded to these guys make France great again
on May 6 Dr Cove as I was called and found her
chest congested her throat inflamed her illness
was dip theia diptheria ah what was that on May
29th last Sacrament was given and she died
oh I didn't even get to see her and no one
thought to notify me it would it was illegal at
the time sir do you you blame me he just always
makes it a about of himself yeah of course you
don't not to Bear the burden of responsibility
this narcissist this Nar I want the letters that
I wrote to her I'm sorry I don't have them they
were stolen by her valy wow where did she keep
them yeah same tissue in the cupet in her Petro
next to her bed next to her heart I'm sorry I
forgive you I forgive you do you blame me of
course not I forgive you he knows his place in
the world Jes this Congregation of allies shall
form along the borders of France and Belgium an
army the muscles from Brussels 120,000 troops
from Prussia This Vermin has routed the farmyards
of Europe are the farmers snort ouch we should
have struck this blow long ago no where's your
loyalty lie man I believe I speak for all of us
when I say that the only regret we all share is
that we allowed This Vermin to live at all wowe
I wish we got to see more of that stuff you were
talking about 125,000 men and 100,000 men against
our 125,000 men this is a fight on land so we
could take them Britain does not know how to
do that I know strike quickly against Wellington
defeat them separately disallow them from uniting
forces here waterloop home of the excellent water
slide es morning so he just like assumed command
yeah enough people faithful to him they were able
to just didn't have to go any work arounds with
the whole I mean they are the the enforcers
so if enough people are just like we follow
this guy what you go to war yeah I mean water I I
believe water L is not going to end well but but
also why would you ruin that John I don't know
this is my guess I'm just judging by where we
are in the movie this is all like we're in
into history I didn't even know about like
I didn't know he came back from Exile and like
got his troops back and tell him make the rain
stop right yes sir right we we'll
get right on that now listen very
carefully patience we must hold
this ground let him come to us oh
boy get a little nap in now there he is he
appears to be just sleeping appearances can't
be receiving I have the emperor in my sight do I
have permission to fire certainly not General's
commanding armies have better things to do with
their time to shoot at one another hold your fire
Rifleman on pain of death wow at 11 to 12 miles
I want to report every hour yes pler p on the
road 12 miles come on Napoleon Prussian troops
have been sighted in the road ready the [Music]
cannons the looks the rain is stopped sir
you boys did good stop the rain God is on our
[Music]
side patience patience with Pati everyone be
patient so eye the ball and get out of the
way that one drummer just got dusted
infantry this seems like a terrible idea yeah
that patience going to come in handy [Music]
now oh not the Cannons I cannot imagine being on
a battle field like [Music] this a wow willhelm
scream oh the amount of dudes exploding in this
movie isn't high but it it's high
enough to catch me by surprise every
time no he's losing his confidence man the
Duke of Wellington prepare to receive Cavalry
prepare to [Music] receive hold our Stand
Fast to the last man we must not be beat
absolutely holy
[__] oh boy oh oh my God whoa what do you
call this formation say it in the name of the
emperor this is terrible plan
Jesus oh my god get back in the
yeah just doesn't have the same old ring as it
used to go die Napoleon go die n he
can't die until they play the ABBA
song wow man that's a hell of a formation
they got wow man what choreographer you got
for the horses and everything to keep
this all in formation it's impressive
wow wa how did they get that shot
it better be an SPCA certification on
this he looks so tired you are the brave of as
Never Surrender for homand and Glory he's going to
die wow dude
wow
it is exhausting being a Sher left's
[Music]
hand everyone just gets like a great shot
everyone who get shot just falls down forward
you know they're not like ah yeah dead there's
instant death everyone maybe that helps though
maybe no matter how bad your adre is maybe you
just lay down and hope that you know I would
just fall on once I fire just fall as lay still
as you can until this is all over and then crawl
away God what a mess what a mess Cavalry
Advance sir Cavalry Advance they really do
capture the the epicness in these War scenes
a lot yeah I just like the high body count
the tangibility how close and personal it
all is such a there's such a roar to it
nice little jab with the stab yeah actual body
count he can't help himself yeah know
he's going to die right now thank
God sure God's not here man he's busy come to
our Marshal of friend yeah they all are just r to
die whoa whoa
dude cut him off at the
retreat don't let him Retreat
yeah oh
damn wow
Plymouth the first battle we've seen him lose
I guess yes or like truly outright lose yeah
it is geometry I simply know precisely where to
place a cannon but tragically I cannot transfer
this knowledge to my Marshals what is most
difficult in life Fair accepting the failures
of others yep must not do that yep man did not
grow at all what are they doing there it's the
M shipment they adore him get him out your
grace morning General his boys are delightful
and this breakfast now I know why you have such
a successful Navy unit runs on its stomach I've
never visited the English Countryside imagine
I love the kwals and my dear sir it is only by
a narrow margin of opinion that you have been
spared the fate of being shot I'm afraid it's
impossible for the British government to allow you
to stay in England is she just like vacationing
right now yep you permitted three officers and
12 servants to accompany you into exile Exile
will be contained to the island of St Helen oh
my God under the watchful eye of Governor Hudson
L and his family would it be better in My Last
Exile it's a small island more of a rock really a
thousand miles from the mainland of Africa W it's
even worse don't have time to reflect sure that
your presence verify twice daily by the orderly
officer you will have an anklet on your ankle
seems like his greatest losses started coming in
the form of when he lost Josephine yeah behind
every Great Dictator it's a great woman I hate
to see you alone my sweet stubborn Emperor I
let you loose and let you come to ruin next time
I will be Emperor and you will do as I say yes
mommy could be worse yeah you are right every
night I beg to see you in my dreams and when
I do you turn me away flies and the wine
can I tell you what I have waiting for you
it is a secret and I will show you when you
arrive come to me Napoleon that's just water
let's try this again go die get that poison
going look at this Godfather three shot right
here died on the 5th of May 1821 after 6 years of
Exile 61
[Laughter]
battles oh my God oh my God one day
excellent where's the French who that uh I
guess just the French alone how many other
casualties oh
boy I'm assuming it was a French who died in
that list because it said in um one of them that
460,000 died and he said that they returned to
troops with only 40,000 so after sting in 500,000
so 500,000 minus 40,000 400 60,000 okay before he
got exiled it said 500,000 troops were sent and
only 40,000 returned was it 500,000 that time I
I'll Trust I'll I'll Trust your recollection very
specific number damn that's wild I mean yeah like
either way whether it's combined or if it's just
French it's still like insane and I mean that
460,000 was like what their combined resources
across their allies right is there a post credit
scene all right reject Nation so today I want to
share something with you that has been a wonderful
addition to my health and fitness journey that
I discovered during the holidays and that is
liquid IV's hydration multiplier I'm down to
my very last packet and I'm freaking out but it's
okay I got more in the mail now a lot of you have
been so kind to notice how I've been working on my
physical health thank you for all the compliments
and one thing I learn is that proper hydration
is absolutely crucial especially post-workout
and pre-filming after post-workout and my wife
actually introduced me to this product which is
perfect because we not only care about quality but
a good taste and quality product we it's after a
sweaty workout or just after you know a good
night out you know what I'm saying efficient
hydration and replenishing electrolytes is key
you just feel better and it tastes fantastic I
can't emphasize that enough another thing I'm
always on the lookout for too is products that
have zero sugar or zero sugar added because that's
one of my main dietary restrictions throughout the
week and they of course got products that fit that
description that also taste good too so yes thank
you so much so liquid IVs hydration multiplier is
in summary is they are a non-GMO electrolyte drink
that delivers hydration into your bloodstream
faster and more efficient than water alone cuz
sometimes drinking a whole gallon is not always
efficient but in fact it can provide the same
hydration as drinking two to three bottles of
water I'm also big on efficiency plus it's packed
with love essential vitamins and we know vitamins
are good for the body it's vegan soy free gluten-
free and dairy free you can customize the water
amount to your taste again perfect for post night
recovery traveling or just having a big night
out you know what I mean noral so if you want
to boost your support for the Channel and boost
your hydration game go to liquid i.com and use
promo code Rejects at checkout that's liquid i.com
promo code Rejects and remember liquid IV it's not
a real IV but sure feels like it so stay hydrated
stay healthy and let's keep crushing those health
and fitness goals together in the year 2024 well
gang if you made it to this point we just finished
watching Ridley Scotts Napoleon why don't you
leave some five star reviews on that Apple music
or Spotify wherever you might be listening to this
and uh we're going to hop into our thoughts on the
movie unless we have anything else to do first
unless there's anything that we ought to dictate
to people yeah no okay well damn uh this has been
an interesting year for movies like this this this
is uh you know a big sweeping epic of sorts but
it's also got a very sort of ironic quality at
the center of it and having seen funny killers
of the flower moon is here on screen they want
us to watch it after the Hunger Games and after
the brick layer in that order um but that movie
kind of makes for an interesting compliment to me
because these are two of the most striking and and
you know talked about movies of the Year from two
veteran filmmakers that both showcase like what
can happen when just like horribleness and and
conniving is left to kind of its own devices and
and when you're in a time where like information
is restricted so you have you know both the
immense possibility of what you know minations can
do and also just like idiocy and and pettiness can
do and whereas Killers is a very austere very
straight movie I felt like this endeavored
to explore similar territory obviously with a
different historical context uh but but with a
much more deeply ingrained sense of yeah irony
humor Etc uh but yeah what what you think sir
um my nice side is just wanting to say mixed bag
sure cuz I can easily pinpoint what I liked about
it yes see it's easy for me to like isolate what
I really like about it it's very easy overall I'm
not sure I like this movie sure to be to sure sure
uh overall I'm not sure I like this movie uh I
think it it it kind of it just felt way edited
down and the I I don't really find the story
itself that enriching of a story it's more like
I watched a bunch of things happen even Napoleon
himself doesn't really have uh things happen for
and to Napoleon but him as a character doesn't
really have a real descent as a as a person or an
arc in any real way like he kind of just starts
off this way and he's a little bit more that guy
by the end of it yeah it's not exactly much of a
uh in terms of a narrative I think it's it's kind
of weak and and and then like we like we're saying
throughout the whole reaction that it just kept
feeling really paired down like with the way they
would handle time jumps and time spans and then
you would have scenes that were like oh this is
kind of like uh emotionally dramatically I'm I'm
into it and then we're just sometime sometimes
we'll do a time Jump without foring you we've done
a Time jump or they they do a time Jump and they
inform you and then it would ultimately lead to
like battle scenes that were really grandiose uh
epic and on scale and shot with such visceral
nature that I haven't seen in any of the 2023
movies to this degree especially in a practicality
scale where it would blend CGI in ways that at
times other than like Cannon and maybe some fire
that I couldn't really tell but like this like
those battle sequence were just beyond epic U
at the same time when I would step back I would
go but I I have like no emotional investment in
in this fight I don't know the soldiers all the
stuff about what Napoleon cares about outside of
Josephine I don't really know uh this this rency
for France I don't understand then he there's
a lot of things that are been like dictated
to me and told to me but again it was kind of
like watching a a a history book it was with
questioning constantly what is real what what is
accurate and what is not accurate uh because and
the reason why I would do that is because I wasn't
lost enough in the narrative to not give a [__]
about that sure I was so aware of uh a lot of the
shortcomings that this movie was doing and like
the first hour I would be like I know I'm enjoying
this there's there's a bit of a farsal element as
we were pointing out and this humorous Touch where
they would use music to that would be in in a fun
jued position where it was like this classical
Elegance while like atrocities are taking place
and it would magnify uh some of the goofiness and
silliness and how these people were kind of a joke
it magnifies the yeah the the weird artifice of
high society in a time especially such as this
where it's like conflict is so tangible but it
lost that sure that humor it lost it lost all that
for me uh in the last like hour and a half of this
film or something some some part of that runtime
the one of the things that was really clicking for
me and then it just starts becoming like we got to
just clip through this and clip through this and
clip through this and out of two and a half hours
I didn't really feel anything when I was watching
it I I was I was watching certain times I would I
would admire something I'm watching or i' be like
oo that's I might react to like a violent scene
um or I might oh he was kind of an [__] here
uh but I I think like the storytelling itself
is is one of the things that I can have an issue
with rly Scott movies nowadays like sometimes he
comes out with a banger um and then other times
it comes out with stuff that just kind of feels
like it's pretty it's great to look at Great cast
um but in terms of like your overall story there's
not much of an impact and I think the impact maybe
there's historians who watch this and are like oh
but seeing this BR maybe that like tickles your
fancy in some way but from just a movie goinging
experience I think it's kind of empty and that's
my biggest issue with it is that uh I I didn't
latch on to anything and it was never even cold
in a way that was um appealing like I like a cold
harsh movie I like I like watching the bad guy
be the main character I I love all those kinds
of film FMS you know but there's a a a there's
still a voice and a and a pull from the heart that
it has to have and and and I felt like this was I
just think it was edited down and sure yeah and I
imagine there's an exceptional is there you kept
saying this thing about a longer Cut Is there is
there a thing about a longer cut yeah yeah there's
going to be like a 4H hour version of this movie
yeah that like shows yeah but unlike Rebel Moon
where I'm like really like I'm not really sure
I want to see a longer cut I'd be curious to see
a longer cut of this one I would I would be I'll
watch the rebel Moon cut but I well in the rebel
moon it's obvious it's appears obvious as to what
might get put back in whereas this you're sort
of like other than fleshing out certain beats of
history that maybe fly by you know there's
a it seems like there's a broader array of
things that that extra time could a lot for you
know rather than clearly there were PL elements
removed you know yeah I think this lacked strong
characterization and and and I keep going back to
the word narrative it's just at the end of the
day you have to tell a story and and so even if
it's a slice of life or something you have to tell
the story there's got to be some kind of narrative
here and it I guess we technically watch the rise
and fall of Napoleon but the way they would handle
the the time when you would jump around time
and then what you chose to focus on in those
times and you see what they have at their hands
at disposal when it comes to a budget that like
oh yeah you could easily probably have like other
scenes on The Cutting Room floor that really got
you hooked into stuff whether it be from just a
the Mind intellectually is more interested or the
heart is more invested and to me this movie kind
of didn't either after like two and a half hours
I was just watching stuff happen with occasionally
being amused by walking Phoenix's performance and
and admiring Vanessa Kirby's work but out of a big
cast I mean like I can't really name anyone else
other than them but there's a lot of people here
like no one really stands out as a performer sure
walking Phoenix kind of felt like again because
of the the story they presented it's it it it's
not really I don't feel like I got to know
Napoleon really yeah I got to know some things
about Napoleon sure some stuff that maybe people
like rumored about what he was like as a person I
can tell how this movie feels about Napoleon but
I never got into the mind of Napoleon I never got
into why Napoleon really is the way he is it's
just things that were alluded to it it never felt
like it got confident enough to embrace a a voice
or his perspective you know like it that's where
I felt like it was at odds were like I could feel
I could feel the Judgment of Ridley Scott of the
story here but in never quite took the perspective
of Napoleon when that's what the movie's doing is
telling it from the perspective of Napoleon while
occasionally cutting to someone else um yeah it
doesn't really extrapolate on his perspect it's
like you understand his perspective and since
it's being told largely from his diluted point
of view it's like you know yeah there's there I
I can see the value in doing that and I can see
why you would want to pitch it that way for a
movie like like this but I do think that other
elements would have to kind of change a bit to
really complement that or to make it feel like
it isn't just you know two and a half hours of
watching like a terrible narcissist never learn
and just you know parade around the world being
petulant and and and yeah like it it is it is an
interesting it's one of these movies and and I'm
not going to I'm trying not to harp on it too
much but there are elements of this experience
that do kind of remind me of the debate that I've
heard and and been somewhat a part of when it came
to killers of the flower mov it's like both of
these movies have this quality where like when
you get what the movie's doing you get what the
movie's doing and and and this movie especially
doesn't really deviate a whole lot from the thing
that it's doing which is to present Napoleon this
guy who has this status in history who clearly
was able to do uh great and devastating things
in equal often simultaneous measure um and there's
something obviously interesting about that in Jos
to our current Society we have many a Napoleon
figure at large in politics and otherwise here
today you know obviously you can draw your through
line to Trump if you want to with the movie like
this but it is that thing of like okay so I can
imagine that really working for somebody for Two
Plus hours and certainly I feel like this movie
like it this is a potentially like a hole is
not as great as the sum of the parts cuz all
the parts are pretty great it's like all the
performances really committed all of the designs
the way that it lives in this time in place to
really sell the tangibility and the harshness
and the contrast between high society and all
the ceremonial stuff that people like to stand
on especially in this moment in time and they
even highlight it on occasion you know polite
society and the the you know extreme depravity
that can be you know propped up on top of that
or you know any number of other atrocious human
elements but yeah it's like the movie doesn't
position itself to extrapolate on why Napoleon
is as as you mentioned or to it's weird it's like
you don't have to show him sympathetically and it
would be a different kind of movie if you did
Endeavor to show things that explain why he is
how he is um but yeah it's like as it exists
here and now I can easily see a lot of viewers
getting to the end and being like okay that was
a lot of miserable and a lot of ironic but yeah
what is this amounting to beyond all of that plus
you know a a quick Sprint through history that I
imagine will probably Pace a little differently
and perhaps a little more Brea thebly for people
who know the history well um but yes for for the
rest of us who are either Rusty or or ignorant
toward a lot of the greater details it does feel
like whoa okay wait hold on we're hopping through
time and even the way they leave the some of the
titles on the screen that are explaining things to
you are like pretty quick and moving along and
uh yeah yeah it is one where it's like there's
so much to appreciate but what it's giving you
you know if you especially if you see it from
early on and that's not enough for you I feel like
this would be a very long experience for a lot of
people no I I think I was just watching facts or
depictions of things uh the entire time you know
if you if you look at a movie like I don't know uh
There Will Be Blood uh for example right um that
movie is a really harsh cold mean movie about one
guy who starts off greedy and he's even greedier
by the end and but he's left lonely and miserable
and he's getting worse and you're watching this
guy like deteriorate into a monster you know like
it's hopelessness for that man by the end and what
he's lost himself to in the pursuit of more and
he's he's completely lonely and and here I use
that as a comparison because there's at least
like a mood about that there's a there's at
least like a terror about that and you're you're
watching the effect it has on other people like
really living in that watching how other people
get lost in the vortex of this man and here I I
feel like they they say things like like the one
guy when he's like his egotism and uh the way he
rules is like the the Paul the dark Paul that he
cast over I'm like all this [__] like I don't
really feel like I saw any of that I don't really
feel like I got any of that of what it was what
he was like really what he was like as a general
other than you watch the battle happen you don't
really see him his mindset as a general um you
don't really see what he's like as a ruler as
an emperor you don't really see all these things
that there saying that he does that are terrible
cuz I'm like from what you've shown me I I would
be like other than him conquering I I'm not really
getting any additional context to understand what
he's done that's made him so such a polarizing
figure what's made him so terrible other than he
he left people down I'm not really being fed that
you know and I'm not seeing why again everything
comes back to why right you you got to you got
to show not tell and this movie relied a lot on
occasionally dro some nuggets of information to
make you go here's why when you you have to let
the audience marinate in some like um whatever it
may be atrocities or the love that you see that
he has and I think the time where they gave the
most delicacy was the thing they were like placing
all their eggs in one basket for was this tragic
romance with uh this Josephine woman uh which
yeah was probably the most interesting part to
me and the movie treats It Like It's the Most most
interesting part about his character and I I think
they lose sight of that like it's it's kind of
it's a to me it's a disjointed experience it's it
lacks focus and it doesn't really know where it
wants to place it's hard and focus at you can't
just cut to a cool battle scene like you can't
you can't just tell me like updates on what's
going on you know that's what this movie does
it's just like an update update the experience
update the timeline uh here's what's happening
and then and then narrative becomes confusing on
Dynamics and relationships and stuff I I I like
what happened with his brother you know there
was a whole thing with his brother like what his
brother yeah totally um that's something I'm just
remembering right now it and and it's a big yeah
I'm not I don't think I like the movie I really
don't it's how it it it plays the concoction of
all these elements because on the one hand I can
see the there there's a lot of the beginnings of
a thread it's like I get the use of the battles
as they juxtapose against the other scenes because
it's all this again when you're just alone in some
big ornate room and it's people talking you know
you're able to really see the disconnect between
again how especially harsh and nasty War at this
point in time is uh and how you know you're so
far removed when you're you know back home or
in some great Mansion plotting all this stuff
and yeah it's like you this that people are behind
him and his TR like part of the reason the moment
with the troops in the wood toward the end right
before waterl kind of worked for me is because I
couldn't tell really what to expect and I was
like oh no he's not going to win them back is
he but I didn't have really reason to go like I
know that these dudes are super dedicated to him
it was so like that moment worked because of of
that but at the same time I feel like the rest of
the movie kind of suffers because of that because
yeah it's like you said we don't really get to see
the soldiers even through his you can still do
that through his perspective but see him being
you know of those people and you know rallying
them to a point where you're like well I see how
dedicated these people are or uh inversely like
throughout the movie he may he makes mention to
like the people for I'm doing this for the people
of France I the people they love me they look to
me and we almost never see the people which again
is I think somewhat intentional and somewhat of a
fair choice because it's illustrating how removed
especially in a time and place like this where
you're confined to just letters and what you can
see and what trusted people relay to you like I
get again the purpose but as it's all executed
here into this Melting Pot it does feel kind
of impersonal and a little disconnected at times
and then you have the romance element which again
kind of reminded me of a killers of the flower
Moon thing where you're watching this clearly
toxic bad situation go down but at the core of it
you're like but maybe in some weird Twisted way
they do love each other although here while I did
appreciate those scenes and the Performing of them
I didn't think it was as strong or interesting as
say it was in Killers because here a lot of those
scenes are like kind of the same scene just in
different years and after different battles and I
didn't really I started to lose the plot in terms
of like I get what his feelings are about her I
can't tell what her actual feelings are and like
she'll write these letters and part of my brain
is going okay I think there's got to be a lot
of ironic double speak in here but she's still
writing him and you know they still maintain this
contact and even after all this and she's like
laughing at him during the divorce proceedings I
I guess she loved him somehow but also I kind of
don't buy it and and and yeah you're left with the
muck of certain of these choices where you're sort
of like I don't really know what what the choice
fully was well I I don't under I don't think they
what could have helped is if they if it seemed
like within the page time that our characters
were aging at all that too and they they don't
they don't I don't feel like any time passes for
our performers like walking Phoenix and Vanessa
Kirby like they just look the same yeah their hair
changes but then you're but but we also live in
a time where everyone's got like 20 wigs so like
yeah you get to the end and I was starting to go
okay like he I guess in the right light he kind
of looks like older and more pale but I feel like
that's just kind of more got to do with like the
performance and the fact that he's like kind of
slowly giving up here at the end you know rather
than it's actually being like a choice within
you know yeah that aspect of the the craft the
whole thing with like being exiled and stuff like
that first year he the movie glosses over that
when he's first exiled he's he's exiled in this
film's runtime for like 5 minutes and I didn't
know as a part of History I need to come back
like I'm like what in my time of experience I'm
not saying I need like an hour I'm saying that I
you this movie Just glosses over it and he's like
I'm tired I'm like well I in my time I I feel
like you just got here you know and it's funny
but I feel like they could have still maintained
that the humorousness of that while also yeah at
least committing to it a little more for so then
a viewer like me can be surprised when it's like
oh I didn't realize he was exiled once came out
of Exile tried to you know do one more coup and
then failed and then got super exiled like I
didn't realize the whole water loop context
that way so yeah yeah I don't know you're right
it's like everything even though this is a movie
that again uh looks like a classical painting and
I like the contrast of how it doesn't behave that
way but but yeah like there's a Grace uh of pace
that I don't think they quite nailed and I wonder
how I would feel if I didn't know that this is
supposed to be longer and certainly again like a
rebel Moon you can tell without having to be told
that whereas this you know I might not have known
as well had I not been aware of that but also I
mean you know you could have easily miniseries
did this yeah I don't think this should be a like
a story with this much time span like I don't know
how you could tell this even in 4 hours I that's
that that honestly feels like it'd be better still
feels like might miss the mark with the amount
they want to tell it still feels a little too
I don't feels like a lot for what this is trying
to do yeah you're trying to span a lot uh uh like
a little too much I think in when with the amount
you're trying to incorporate because again even a
movie like There Will Be Blood you don't really
know why he is the way he is but they they give
you other things to really feed off of and sink
your teeth into and you spend enough time with
other characters to get some of that development
yeah whereas here you know uh I don't need to know
exactly why he loves France but to for it to
really drive like a wedge between the marriage
so much and then for his desire for more like I
need some conflict that truly arises from that you
know I need something more some kind of personal
Hollywood it up a little bit would you something
it's moving quick enough that it just feels like
well this is just how he thinks so naturally he
just need to ascend to the highest level of rule
because this feels this still feels like a movie
you know this still feels like a Hollywood film it
doesn't feel like oh I'm stepping into a moment in
time and that's okay I'm totally okay with it
feeling like a film uh but if you're going to
do that then Hollywood say Hollywood it up then
create some drama create some real conflict here
do something to to give it that extra that that
little Sizzle so that way that that way we're were
on board for some of the more dramatic Journeys
and stuff like that or or have something to care
about but I didn't care about anything that was
happening man I I did not care like it is one of
those Cinema films where you go through the first
hour and you're like some pretty cool some good
craft on display and then you get past a point
and you're like that Goodwill's worn up but this
is moving the at the same this is moving with the
same sensibility and it isn't showing any sign of
yeah of you know picking up a thing or descending
into it thing it it seems like and especially with
a a character you know will have a significant
fall even if you don't have the details it it
does start to feel like you're just going to
kind of see a collection of events until it's
done rather than feeling like you're going on a
journey that has a momentum of a story like this
needs a Martin scares he Touch of of of a rise and
fall of a of a of an individual where you see like
the glory that he got to experience of why he'd
want that back yeah when he's like talking with
the children who admire him like I got no sense
of this world that has been developed here that
these that that there would be children who would
want to like hear from him I got no sense I'm like
how I'm so confused on the level of respect
because I'm mainly checking in with the other
political people who just dog this guy you know
so I'm I'm not really in tune with how everyone
else views him so that's why when the soldiers do
come around I'm like oh this is kind of a surp oh
my God he's leading them into fighting with the
[__] you yeah I think this is a case where
you could benefit and hey rley Scott I mean like
respect to Ridley Scott because again like half
the time he shows back up these days and I'm like
damn dude you be cranking out movies like you know
these if you spent maybe all of that time on half
as many movies maybe they would all be a little
bit better but you know like he's a pro obviously
and and something like this especially during the
first half I was like man though you know even at
his age and as long as he's been at this Ridley
is really you yeah and and it's a a Marvel that
this looks as good as it does you know for again
the fact that he does stay so busy and it is as
tangible as it is like it feels dug into but yeah
like I don't associate him with the same level of
human thoughtfulness like you know Ridley Scott
stuff can be big on ideas but I feel like and
and just continuing on this scorsi Touchstone
like I do feel like he is a filmmaker who has a
certain level of compassion that can carry like
even if you're watching a killer of the flower
Moon who has a lead character and many of your
lead characters are like unsavory people half
of them dumb and narcissistic and whatever else
there's still like you can tell that the author
of this is looking compassionately at like how the
humanity of the situation got this way and I don't
feel like this movie has its eye very much on that
which I think I don't need like a full like I
personally got to know the the tragedy of uh
of Napoleon like you know you can still be a bit
cynical or you can still be a bit of a satire or
a farce but I think yeah that that humanist angle
could have helped to temper a lot of things across
this okay it's got a 58% critic score 59% audience
score okay wow the critic score and audience score
are very much in sync with each other sure yeah
that is very very much in sync yeah that's like
wild you never see that I I actually expected one
of them to be high like significantly higher than
the other mhm oh that's low um I like the house
of gu that was all right oh I want to see how
so Gucci it's not ter I I didn't mind it I didn't
love it but I liked it last duel I just can't find
my can't muster the strength to watch them I just
can't can't muster the strength to watch it when I
heard I'm like I don't know I want to sit through
that I just don't want to sit through it and it's
the one movie like that too where I constantly
heard people going like actually those of us
who went saw it it's like it's pretty it's one of
his best and even still I'm just like I still just
don't know if I'm going to if I even care I just
don't want to experience that yeah like I for when
this maybe in like 10 or 15 years when we're far
removed from like the moment in time that it was
also co-opting to to come into existence yeah
but uh yeah I mean damn made the Martian 2015
[__] I mean yeah like must I mean according
to Ryan Tomato's last duel seem like his last
great film which was only in 2021 like like his
one that's like oh people think this is a great
movie you know yeah and that's the thing is he
hasn't gone to that place yet where he like makes
one movie every six years so it it's like I guess
it's easier to look at Really Scott as having lost
the touch but then be reminded like but every few
movies he has one that people are like this is at
least better than just good or maybe even great
so like you know I I'm torn because I'm glad to
see him still out there still kicking and still
you know showing you know that he's got those
chops but also there are times where yeah I feel
like he his kogin liness of the here and now maybe
gets in the way of something that could impact a
little bit more pressingly and and uh permeating
L so to speak yeah because I mean clearly there's
tons and tons of artistry on display um alrighty
well okay I'm good John yeah we're good well
gang what you guys think do you love Napoleon
now do you sympathize with him leave us your
thoughts what was your favorite aw Contender of
2023 leave it in the C M M N T's and hey before we
get out of here let's do a patron of the day shout
out Michael B omn media happy New Year Michael B
alrighty guys let me get this out of the way he
has a YouTube channel called omn media where he
does reactions he's been on this channel with us
I've done a few movies with him to cover tales
of the Jedi John covered a mission impossible
with him one movie I said you could have one
one movie and Counting um well you know what
man I think for 2024 this whole like promoting
you thing has to come to an end far because your
channel I'm seeing is doing better now uh-uh and
frankly I got a hint of a being threatened why
would you do that to us this whole like reactor
community of we got to stick together and help
each other out yeah yeah yeah it's all just a a
bunch of of of of figing pleasantries is what we
do but we all know that we want to dominate one
another and I don't care what kind Deeds you've
done I don't care how long you've been pledged
to our patreon page your success is out of spite
your [__] has to end now all right do you be
as successful as you want but from here on out
no more plugging Omni media I will not be shouting
out o Emma and mother and is and Nancy the number
one media I don't want to do that anymore because
watching your reactions to Reacher oh SOA uh Echo
uh all the movies you've been covering with these
great looking thumbnails and wonderful commentary
and then every time I open up your videos and
just see like man this guy gets like nothing
but positive comments because he's that good I'm
sick of talking about it dude absolutely sick of
promoting o as an oh my God he's still here M
as man why do we still keep promoting him n as
in no we no longer promote omn media one as
in there can only be one like Highlander and
then media as in I'm going to stop watching
his media stop watching the media yeah Omni
media yeah Omni media but in in seriousness
you know succeed as much as you can oh yeah
and um you know come up with some goals for
this year yeah yeah yeah think of how you can
improve your operation without uh you know out
stripping ours happy New Year you [Music] dick